[Music]
God Bless the
USA Donald Trump swept the Iowa caucuses
winning from one end of the state to the
other and cementing his place as the one
to beat in the Republican race for
president the victory in the contest of
the 2024 presidential campaign marked a
historic comeback for the former
president and the official beginning of
his goal of ousting President Joe Biden
in returning to the White House we want
to thank the great people of Iowa thank
you we love you all what a turnout what
a crowd and I really think this is time
now for everybody our country to come
together we want to come together uh
whether it's republican or democrat or
liberal or conservative it came after
two impeachments As Trump faces 91
criminal charges which seemed only to
buoy him in polls and in the eyes of his
supporters from here I really see it as
beginning in Iowa and ending in Kansas
Mar in late March is when going when
there's going to be the Kansas primary
and about that time if we keep this up
that's about the time that he'll cross
the threshold of winning the
convention Florida Governor Ronda santis
exceeded expectations narrowly edging
out Nikki Haley who had surged past him
in recent polls we have a lot of work to
do but I can tell you this as the next
president of the United States I am
going to get the job done for this
country I am
not I am not going to make any excuses
and I guarantee you this I will not let
you down thank you all God bless you
thank you so the tight race for the
silver medal leaves the battle to become
the alternative to Trump unresolved but
Haley who's better positioned in the
upcoming races in New Hampshire and her
home state of South Carolina claimed a
kind of Victory underestimate me because
that's always
fun
I love you Iowa but we're on to New
Hampshire turnout was well below record
levels temperatures dipping to- 22 C
with wind chills of- 32 appeared to keep
many people at home there's an old adage
that Iowa punches three tickets for
candidates to move forward in the race
that seemed to be confirmed on Monday
when the ramaswami came in a distant
fourth and ended his campaign
thank you very much the race moves on to
New Hampshire next Tuesday with Trump
hoping to gain momentum in the second
and third place candidates fighting to
remain in the race John hendin Al jazer
de Mo
Iowa make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer